see youtubers is Charlie so we had to
talk about how Arya Stark is going to be
the most valuable character to Jon Snow
in season 7 because of the stuff that
she's done so far so just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show up through season six
because of the way the TV show has
changed her character just a little bit
from the books she's actually much more
powerful on the TV show so she is like
The Punisher that's why I'm wearing my
Punisher t-shirt right now but there's a
new round of the game of Thrones
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just for a copy of one
of the enhanced editions of the books so
be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything
during the off season so number seven
Arya the most valuable character what
does that mean isn't Jon Snow isn't
Daenerys aren't they the most valuable
characters Daenerys controls her dragon
Jon Snow is now king of the north there
are a number of characters that wield
power in different ways those will be
very very important down the road but
right now they're both characters that
are in transition they're largely
shackled to their forces like Jon Snow
can't do whatever he wants to do he's
trying to figure things out in the way
the TV shows presented him is that he is
not the best leader of men that's going
to be one of the big challenges he has
in season 7 is Leo leading small groups
of people in earlier seasons went really
well but how is he going to deal with
the collected forces of the North Arya
Stark on the other hand currently is the
most valuable character because she's
not bound to anyone even though she's
serving her family but she can go
anywhere steal any face that she wants
so she has complete free rein of the
Seven Kingdoms and there are a couple
things that she's trying to do right now
number six
revenge is her mission she is The
Punisher this season so while there
might be at some point in the future
where she's riding with her family on
horseback charging an open field that's
not really what she does she trained as
an assassin with the faceless men this
whole time so that she could use those
skills in they're probably going to be
taking advantage of that in season 7 so
what did she just do she just
assassinated Walder Frey and his sons
there were some minor changes
with the way they presented that the TV
show version of Aria just got way more
powerful than the book version so some
of those changes is why she became so
much more powerful than the other
characters so number five as of right
now she controls the twins because she
can wear Walder Frey's faith she could
wear anyone's face that she wants so the
twins themselves is actually a very
important location because it's
basically the only way to get an army
between the north in the southern
kingdom so you're either stuck in the
north or you're stuck in the south so
she could be very valuable to Jon Snow
in the forces of the north if they try
to march on Cersei but she could also be
a huge pain in Cersei that stopping any
of her forces from marching north so I
say she's important for Daenerys his
character too but Daenerys has it made
landfall and Westeros yet she doesn't
know who ari is Arya has never met her
so she's not thinking about her she's
just thinking about more revenge her
list and her family so number four the
Punisher controls the twins chaos reigns
but because there's so few episodes this
is probably going to be more useful to
getting troops out than from keeping
troops from getting north number three
crossing more names off the list this is
where things get interesting
because the Hound is still on her list
but so is the mountain I know everybody
wants to go for cleganebowl 2.0 it was
renewed hope after the Hound joined the
Brotherhood during season six so people
are like it could still happen down the
road eventually they will have to clash
forces in the hand will be there but
there are only a couple characters on
Arya's list that are still alive on the
TV show right now including Cersei the
Hound in the mountain and I think we can
agree that over the course of season six
Arya made it pretty clear how she feels
about the hound
so even if she ultimately crosses him
off her list he is the last person that
she would cross off so that we've Cersei
in the mountain in the mountain is never
far from Cersei so they kind of come
hand in hand what she's been doing this
last episode is just avenging her
family's death at the red wedding so
that meant taking care of Walder Frey
and all his sons everybody that she knew
was responsible she doesn't know
everyone that would
involved she just knows that the phrase
were mostly responsible and that the
Lannisters sent their regards
so there are a number of ways she could
find herself in proximity to the
Lannisters like Jaime and Cersei so
Jaime and Cersei seem like they're going
to be separated for most of the season
anyway because Jamie is leading the army
but you get the sense that aria does not
discriminate because she baked all of
the phrase into pies so she is hard core
so she's going after Lannisters now but
even though sir she's at the top of the
list it doesn't mean that she's going to
spare every other Lannister so number
one valonqar Theory Cersei is going to
die at the hands of the younger one
little brother little sister the
language is gender neutral everyone just
interprets it as little brother you know
she will meet her end at the hands of
the little brother people used to think
that it was Tyrion early on but now
people seem to think that it's going to
be Jaime but because of the way the TV
show has changed
Arya's base-stealing she is now capable
of stealing Jaime's face to use it to
kill Cersei so poetically Aria is now
the most powerful character and in
fulfillment of that prophecy you get a
younger brother killing Cersei which
sort of wraps up Jaime and Cersei zart
the way Jaime became a good person
Cersei embraced a darker path but you
also get arya being able to cross off
all the names on her list so it's just a
solution that allows them to wrap up all
those storylines in a really satisfying
way but it also makes sense for the
characters Jaime very tragic figure
wants to die in the arms of someone he
loved so you could imagine that Arya
will somehow kill Jaime at some point
but Jaime seems like he is also destined
to kill Cersei in the way that he killed
the Mad King just because Cersei has now
become a version of the Mad Queen so you
ask how is that possible this is where
the TV show changes come in so what the
TV show has changed about the books and
face stealing is is it typically when
you steal a face in the book like the
shape of your body does not change it's
really just the face part and you know
you can change your facial structure
just a little bit but that's about as
far as it goes it's almost like you're
wearing a mask it just looks very very
convincing but on the TV show
aurilla was able to go from being a
little girl to a much taller more fully
developed woman so what the TV show is
saying is that she could almost steal
anyone's face and it would be a
convincing replacement now like imagine
her trying to steal the mountain face
that probably wouldn't happen I'd be
taking it too far she can't go from
being like a little five foot tall
person to being like an 8 9 foot tall
person this is be ridiculous most of the
way they shoot these scenes they cheat
that so you know they don't really give
away the fact that she's either really
tall really short so you guys let me
know how far do you think that Aria is
going to take her face stealing in
season 7 so she can steal Walder Frey's
face she can steal anyone's face that
she wants she just became the most
valuable character to Jon Snow and his
forces I would say the most powerful
character you kind of have to say from a
narrative perspective because it depends
on what kind of power you're talking
about because there are people with
powerful magic but they're sort of
shackled to their roles like Daenerys
can't just take her dragons and conquer
everyone by herself so she's very
powerful right now very important in the
fight against the White Walkers
but bran for instance has much more
powerful magic so maybe I should make
that my next bonus video like ranking
the actual most powerful people based on
how powerful their magic is because
typically as you get weaker and weaker
people's magic gets more and more
powerful so Melisandre is a very
powerful person because she has great
magic but Brant who is even weaker like
he has a giant physical disability he
has to be carried around on a litter has
much more powerful magic that he's still
trying to figure out but because so many
of you have been requesting more Game of
Thrones videos I've only been doing
about one a week I'm going to start
doing more so YouTube is actually giving
me some upgrades that will make it
easier for you guys to communicate that
with me like I can pick it out of the
comments but sometimes stuff like that
gets buried so let me know what you want
my weekly videos about Game of Thrones
to be about series or explaining
concepts or groups of people or history
anything you guys want and like I said I
think the trailer is probably at least
another month or two away they did drop
the parody trailer with John Oliver but
that's like a trailer for all their HBO
shows congratulations to this week's
book giveaway winner one true ioke
please private message me
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video I'll
just announce the winner the next time I
post a game of Thrones video where you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my Cersei theory and you can
click here to rewatch on logan red band
trailer thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you